the guidelines for brexit talks were
endorsed just minutes after the meeting
began in Brussels
it was a clear message of unity to
London
we now have unanimous support from all
the 27 member states and the EU
institutions giving us a strong
political mandate for these negotiations
the leaders agreed to a faced approach
with a number of golden rules for phase
one golden rule number one first you
talk about separation and only then the
future relationship leaders of France
and the Netherlands said the UK would
need to pay a price for leaving but
along with the German Chancellor they
also said the EU did not mean to punish
Britain thus via Zeeman sponsor
influences honesty for the 27 of us now
trying to forge a common position I
think it's the most natural thing to do
we have 27 here who are negotiating and
one who has asked to leave that's just
the way things are it doesn't mean that
we are united against someone it is
actually easier for Britain if we speak
with one voice haha does via Medina
stimulation boil golden rule number two
the divorce issues no heart border
between the Republic of Ireland and
Northern Ireland the protection of the
rights of 3 million EU citizens in the
UK and finally the brexit bill however
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
said the EU hasn't yet arrived at a
total sum it once Britain to pay a skip
congestion there is no bill of sixty
billion euros that the EU has presented
Britain with in what we have is a
cautious estimate but nothing precise as
yet King in the gain reduction procedure
familiar member the EU members pledged
they would also stick together against
potential British efforts to divide and
conquer it was the first and the last
time that we were able to conclude in
four minutes so don't expect us to keep
the same speed it will never happen
again the EU has laid out its position
and now it must see if the you
Hey wants to play by its golden rules